歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是艾倫
今天吐了
把昨天的東西吐了
吐了一乾二淨
昨天漲800多點
今天跌將近800點
沒錯 就這樣一天
我昨天錄節目來說
你看我們開盤就這樣
蹭蹭蹭上去
今天開盤就下去了
可是昨天其實我們也有聊
有可能叫做棒打出頭尿
因為昨天我們台股叫做世界第一強
其實整個8月的漲幅
我們好像也是世界第一強
對
我看到日本今天其實是跌破小平台
那我們台灣股市是回測五日均
我們今天就是原地踏步
不過今天盤很有趣
我剛本來想要考艾倫
我說請艾倫隨便講一講
你今天跌停的股票
結果艾倫就
愣住
就說他不要跟我講話了
有嗎我有這麼任性嗎
因為今天是沒有股票跌停板的
原來是這樣
上市跟上櫃都沒有
所以並不恐慌
只是因為我們現在看到
美伊戰爭確實越打越熱
現在九月升息的機率高達70%
非常高
原本上禮拜四的時候還在35%
對
睡個兩天過個假
週末70%
好
那會不會等到聯準會要開會的時候
又降下去呢
我们常讲危机就是转机嘛
我们竟然强了这么久
休息一下也无妨
只是现在市场有点觉得
油价又逼近100块钱了
94跟90
对啊 越来越高了
没错 那升息机率也上去了
怎么办
台股有没有自己独强的本事
其实台湾股市最近还是
我觉得还是很厉害
虽然今天比较弱势一点
但其实还是很多个股表现很强
什么CPU啊
对啊 工学啊
所以我觉得这个行情
目前来说台湾股市
當然會受影響
但我會比較偏向的是
選股不選市
我們等一下技術面上會再講
我們先來看一下
到底還又要幹嘛了
就是這個在禮拜一的時候
其實就有出現一些利空了
就是美國又跟伊朗打起來
那中間台紙夜盤這樣跌下來
有一瞬間就是
有兩艘郵輪被轟炸了
那就是美軍去轟炸了
這一個伊朗政府的郵輪
那這個帶動的是什麼狀況
就是郵價WTI重返到90那布蘭特來到了15塊左右所以這個油價又推升了大家對於通膨升息的預期那目前升息的機率呢
來到了接近7成 68.2%
那這個就9月16號才會見真章
所以下下禮拜
好 撐一下 大撐一下
我們這中間還有機會的
非農 對
CBI 沒錯
其實 各項的一些總金數據
希望可以一個比較低的狀態
那这个升息的机会就会降低
那目前来说
10年期的美债殖利率
来到了4.79%
已经是20个月的新高
然后30年期是回到上一次
贝森特说要回购的
前一波高点附近
那整个就带动了科技股的表现
会稍微比较弱势一点
因为这个去估值
然后那个资金流动
对 排挤效应等等
那带动就是
其实美国不好
那我们日股表现也比较弱势一点
日本今天跌了接近三个百分点
韩国接近四个百分点
谈股是1.6
我们还是超级厉害
而且这次不只是美国的央行
日本央行也说要升息
我们来看一下刚刚提到
日本供债殖利率来到了
30年来的新高
这真的很猛
以前在日本借钱不太需要利息
五年前是快要负利率
现在3%对我们来说是
很夸张的事情
所以你买日本的债券
每年就给你3%的利息
夸张
1998年
1996年到现在
没错
30年
那目前来说
其实日本的一个
殖利率的上升
也会变相去推升
美国的压力
对
美债3%加上汇率风险
就会干嘛
我就卖美债
我回来买日债
那美债这个被卖
那值率會怎樣
右上升 這什麼循環
很奇怪
然後再來日元套利
會有一個去槓桿的狀態
因為大家都是跟日本借錢
因為日本以前的利率很低
可是如果日本的利率拉起來
我這些借錢的人怎麼辦
還沒合
那買合要幹嘛
跑去日本還錢嘛
本來不就已經還過一次了
還不完啊 已經太多嘛
再還一次
是的 那還了要幹嘛
錢要從哪裡拿
就是科技股
要先賣科技股
然後換成美金
然後美金再回去還日元
所以這一系列呢
可能也會帶動科技股的一個價格去做回落對 那目前來說大家還是不用再真的太緊張因為殖利率上升不代表股市會避跌當然短線上確實
基本上殖利率上來
那短線可能反應就是直接回落
至少就是壓力
是的 但是真正的狀態
目前來說
我們還可以不用這麼擔心
是因為目前AI的發展
所以它這一塊獲利
是遠遠可以去壓過
这个总金的风险的
而且我其实还是觉得
华许游游升息的机会
真的不太大
你真的很有侧词
在这个FED的升息机率
70%的时候
对啊
因为它真的是左右为难
我还是觉得还有空间
本来是两周后的事情
我们到时候再说
这边是川普
又会是贝森特
是的
我们刚刚讲完了一些
可能总金的一个潜在风险之后
我们来看一下有一些
这个产业的利多
就是代額公布财报了
这个盘后涨了8%
上次也是代額
对 那时候涨了2、30%
大家都没想到是他
对啊 想不到这种
越平淡如奇的
这个爆发力更好
目前来说呢
本季470亿
年增58%历史新高
夏季财测呢
490亿
还会继续增加
是年增81%
全年上修1920亿
调整后EPS呢
7.04块
203%两倍哦
然后再来
下一季会6.5块
然后呢
全年上修到25.5块
然后再来是积压订单
积压订单
对 就是潜在
就是基本上之后数字会
会实现的一些
潜在的未来
反正就未来订单
未来营收
未来要收钱进来
是 全年销售740亿
那他有去提到
目前呢
记忆体确实还是最缺的
这两个都记忆体
然后呢
承收制程
基板电源散热光学元件
全面吃紧
是的
所以不只是大廠很想要
就是需求很大
是連供給都跟不太上
所以目前看起來
應該也是非常不錯
再來另外一個就是Google的這一位
首席技術長暨AI基礎設施
資深副總
有偷偷來到台灣
哇 赫達特
洽談下一代TPU伺服器的訂單
傳出呢
2028年來到了1500萬的需求
1500萬 科嗎
應該是科
好 等一下來確認一下
好的 那我們來看一下
剛講完了就來看一下
這個目前談戶股市的狀況昨天我們說到這個N字型去拉出來了對所以拉出來呢這個我就還是會抱著一個比較樂觀的狀態雖然今天呢出現了一根把昨天紅K吃掉而且跌破五日均線的一個
吞噬K棒出現
我剛剛有問說這叫什麼啊
這吞噬K啊
就叫吞噬K啊
對…黑吃紅啊
那黑吃紅呢還跌破五日均
所以這個短線上確實比較沒有這麼
極速就有樂觀的現象
對 因為昨天有點我們自己開心
因为是自己家半导体的大事
对 但是呢
我还是觉得还是不错
因为它昨天是创高
然后创高之后
今天的压回有几个状态
第一个量缩
回到一兆内的成交量
所以价格量缩可以
然后再来我们有说到
昨天观察短的均线是10日均线
观察这一段的是20日均线
目前来说
基本上明天有回落
我们可以观察一个重点
就是会不会开机走高
开机走高脚拉得够长
那就是整理结束的讯号
所以我目前還是不太悲觀
就是這邊的N字形都還在
那回落碰一些
這一波慣性的一些軍線
它只要有收繳
其實我覺得應該都是新買電
相對的真的什麼時候要悲觀
就月線跌破 前滴跌破
那我覺得該保守還是要保守
但我不會因為一天的這樣子的回落
就覺得這行情完蛋了
因為我覺得還不至於
當然可能明天就有可能完蛋
因為我們又是一樣
錄影的同時夜盤又開始了
是的
咕嚕咕嚕咕嚕
只是要跟他說
就不要因为一天的跌
就好像全面否定它
对那只是要更多讯号去做确认
那再贵买其实更强
贵买今天跌幅1%内
而且它今天五日均线没跌破
然后季线也都守得好好的
所以贵买今天也亮说
所以贵买其实相对大盘来讲
这个走势我觉得更没有问题
就整理也没有吞噬的样子
然后量能萎缩
五日均线没跌破
其实贵买是很强的
贵买很强就表示我们什么
还很有机会
中小型个股还很有机会
所以我觉得看到贵买
我会更加不悲观一点点
而且昨天有提到贵买要跟上加权
对不对
那他现在今天就展现出
你们总经打你们的
我们钟晓章我们自己的
是是是今天真的还是蛮厉害的
所以我觉得选股不选市
还是目前的核心操作的逻辑
那我们来看一下几个全资股
首先第一个是伪创
伪创今天的围影先除权
好 先除权
几乎是一张等于三张
对那原本伪创也被带起来
那可是後面行情比較疲軟
整個就帶上引線了
可是目前來說我覺得還不錯
這平台有手
那今天站回月線
原本是這裡如果能夠站上
箱形會更漂亮
可惜沒有
但目前來說應該整個形態上
還是偏漂亮的
所以我覺得偽創這邊
上升趨勢結束了嘛
所以開始整理
但整理下這邊平台開始打出來
其實我覺得可以好好關注
有沒有機會有下一段的
漲幅可以做期待
再來另外一個就是人寶
因為人寶跟代爾
這個是配合是有的
那目前來說人寶
我們前一陣子這邊是
比較強勢的中央
因為那時候ODM都很強
那這個時候就是那個時候
那個代爾的來勢
就带人来台湾参加
台北国际电脑站
没错
那目前来说
整个上升趋势都还在
但人保呢
它就是
就整个ODM就温温的啦
对 所以目前看起来
它的月线上升趋势
现在都还在
但是呢
如果是成交量
还是这样萎缩的状态
就会比较没有表现的机会
那可以等待一下
像这里开始起涨的时候
其实都会开始陆续放量
等出现类似这样的成交量的时候
就可以关注一下
形态还在
那开始放量
就会是下一波新的攻击讯号
所以大家可以持续去观察一下
其实如果是组装代工
其实蛮稳的
即使现在总经情况上面
有一点压力
所以他们可能
这种比较大型的股票
是涨不太动
可是对应到明年
已经看到代尔电脑的成绩的话
是不用担心
但大家可能也希望
要比较活泼的
昨天我们跟大家聊到的
就是CPO
里面讲到的领头羊大力光
今天被宣布关紧闭了
但是今天在盘面上
光学概念是非常强劲的
所以选股不选市的情况下
下一段艾伦就要讲
大力光 玉金光现在都被关了
那其他会不会拿到资金呢
待会儿来聊
好的 来吧
我们来看一下吧
我们昨天沈预言
我们都跟你讲大力光在涨
就要被关了
被关了
是的
对
二哥今天先被關
二哥玉金光今天關
大力光明天關
大家一起關
那目前來說
整個光學鏡頭
不只是CPU
其實相關的一些中端運用
他們都還是會用到鏡頭的
目前來說有光通訊
這個應該是最熱門的其中一個
再來AI手機
無人機
然後跟兩年前最夯的機器人
這些基本上都是需要
至少要偵測那個地方是什麼東西
他才可以去用后面的电脑去辨别我要做什么事情所以目前来说在这個行情走到這個階段的過程中CPU帶領了一波新的熱潮
也帶領了光學鏡頭
今天的表現是非常強的
這一陣子
那只要大哥們續搶
我們這一些小弟們
就有機會來分一杯羹
完全不像今天的盤面
完全就像是延續昨天的盤面
對啊 你看一下
這個今天沒有黑色的
而且都漲個3 5%以上
你看一看
你不知道今天台灣股市跌
跌快800點
而且以前一直在救亞光有沒有
機器人的視覺什麼的都不會理
不用救了
終於來了
是的 終於來了
所以今天整個光鏡頭的族群性是有的
跟昨天我們來討論的是一樣的
看高做低
CBO看高做低
今天我們的光鏡頭
當然也是CBO領軍
但是我們在光鏡頭這個族群裡面
也來看高做低
不過雖然加速不多
這貧富差距有點大
大哥都要8千了
這下面的40差很大
所以到底在型態上面
因為你等一下會來介紹
我們應該優先看的是領先群
還是真的要買落後群
會不會落後的追不上
我覺得一定會有這種狀況出現
因為其實這一次拉起來
它是某一個題材
那個題材是CPU
所以大力光其實應該就只有
他跟郁靜光是在直覺
受惠CPU這個大題材的
但淋漪光是材料类的
所以跟着受惠嘛
对 所以目前来说
你可以看到这几个走势上
它那个应该就是
非常非常非常右上角
但其实光镜头来讲的话
如果我们回到一个
刚提到的概念是
大哥在冲
但大哥哪一天一定会冲不动了
那如果大家还想要在这个族群
因为强势族群嘛
我资金还是想从里面琢磨
一定会有资金往低位阶去做移动
所以我目前还是比较偏向
喜好低位阶转强
但我不是说涨多就不能追
那就停损抓好
比如说五日均线
大力光 玉金光 延一光
五日均线 十日均线跌破
我就停损出场
看有没有机会继续高还能更高
但另一部分就是
底部有转强 出量的
那也许也可以参考一下
好 因为我们刚刚有讲说
玉金光 大力光都被关
大力光在被关的这一天
投信还在买
可是被关了
交易就会开始出现
比较不顺畅
也许资金就会扫到他们的身上
所以我们就可以来看一下了
我们来先看一下两个高的
其實還有一個聯誼光啦
對 但我們今天就舉
大的跟二的 跟第二個大哥跟二哥來看一下型態那型態當然目前都沒有太大的問題就是一個非常右上角的這個強勢的7995 差五塊錢
沒錯
然後呢
預金光是已經到1090了
千元股
這個成交量萎縮
是因為進處置了
不過呢
都是碰五日均都拉
碰五日均就拉
所以整個多方的形態
我個人認為
完全沒有太多的問題
但有的問題就是說
我現在還能買嗎
是
這個問題就非常的深奧了
對不對
所以呢如果有的就可以报
问就是买啊
哦 ok
所以有就可以报啦
如果没有你现在要再买
那我们就回到一个问题了嘛
有没有低位阶可以买嘛
所以我们今天来看几个
低位阶的个股
首先呢第一个来看的呢
就是金国光
哦
金国光呢
其实不要看啊
金国光是什么东西
没有哦
人家今年的上半年营收
是非常不错的哦
上半年营收呢年增了58%
然后呢税后存余2.75亿
年增140%
14倍
沒有是1400%
然後就14倍
那EPS呢
已經上半年就賺盈
這個去年整年了
所以營收應該還是非常有表現的
那目前來說形態上
我們也來關注一下
這個位階也非常的低
這叫W底嗎
應該可以偏向三重底
對可以偏向三重底
但不管是哪一個底
我們可以注意的就是
N字型也確立了
然後這個頸線的位置
在前兩天也去做突破了
成交量在這幾天也都陸續的去放大
所以在目前來說
只要大力光 玉金光
不要面臨連續性的修正
其實他們就只要在高檔上撐著
這些中小型的同族群的
應該就有資金去做移動的效應
所以我覺得目前來說
形態上打好了
位階又偏低
你看嘛這個前高還有一點距離
然後這邊底部剛確立
所以我覺得這個空間是還有的
好 大力光有人說
要挑戰五位數
那剛剛玉金光是四位數
這好歹三位數吧
加減一下吧
是不是加減前面高低有三位數
對 所以目前來說
我們這個
目前我的選股概念
都會變成是有強勢族群
然後去找低位階的專強來做
這個其實跟雲翔哥有點像
好
雲翔哥那時候我唯一記憶猶新
就是軍工
長王航太有沒有
這樣子拉上去
但是一定要整體有族群性
這一套work起來才會順
沒錯所以這個經過光第一個幫大家介紹一下再來第二個就是雅光好雅光其實獲利算不錯的對喔但雅光也沉積了很久
這個是拉比較近
但是如果你把它往後再翻到
其實大概有一年的時間
我記得我們還聊過
它算是對等關稅之後
幾乎沒有漲的工資
對 到現在也沒有漲
對
它就是在這個區間內
做一個區間震盪
但是近期有做了一個紅K的表態
那雅光跟大家講
這就是之前
它有大概兩年前
機器人剛起步的時候
亞光那個時候是
最強勢的指標股之一
那時候從二三十塊
標到兩三百塊
那目前來說亞光
進入大區間震盪之後
今天這幾根紅K
開始有一些陸續的表現
幫大家找的也是一樣
就是這種平台剛去做突破的
然後突破之後
它其實昨天已經有先
創一波高
但全部被壓下來
那今天直接把
昨天的大量吃掉
所以它這邊的
一個轉折的情緒
我覺得應該是非常強的
所以今天剛轉強
我們先挑戰一下近期的小高點
那如果大家把K棒再往後拉遠一點
其實它有個大高點
那個距離就會非常的大
所以我覺得是有價差空間的
那亞光線來講
剛突破 剛站回全部均線
有一個大紅K的表態
我覺得族群性都還在
就可以找這種低位接
來去做操作
好 這個是亞光的部分
好的 再來看到下一個就是中陽光
好 這個又更低位階了
還不到50
是的 這個位階我覺得非常非常的低
那裡面有相關的無人機鏡頭
剛剛這個 幫大家回顧一下
這邊呢 經過光它是紅外線鏡頭
對 然後還有那個低軌衛星的鏡頭
對 所以這個是其中一個題材
那亞光是機器人題材
然後呢 剛剛現在要講的這個
中陽光它是無人機
也等於說他們如果要直接跳到
所謂CPU
也許是離得比較遠
我覺得是有難度的
對 可是在有領頭陽的情況下
其他的鏡頭類
其實也是長期被低估的一個狀態
是的 其實光鏡頭這個族群
我覺得之前的
因為大力光是躺在地板上
那一陣子嘛 之前
所以大家其實光鏡頭的
琢磨是非常少的
對 那目前來說
我們大力光就是這種一樣嘛
就是一人得到雞犬升天
所以大家就升天了
好 中央方
我們來看一下
還沒 還沒升天
你看它這個線型
對啦 你的拉遠一點
其實它就也還是長這樣子
對 可是目前來說
我們都關注一下
就是開始在這邊底部有放掉
的訊號出現了
這邊也是一個底部
然後佔回了全部均線
然後呢這個多方缺口
到今天第五天了
都沒有去跌破過
所以我覺得第一方面
停頌點好抓
那一方面這邊五日均線
已經跟上來了
所以乖離均線的那個
乖離已經縮斂到一定程度了
那量能放得夠大
這邊的高點就合理
有機會去做突破
所以目前來說
我覺得也可以去關注一下
我進場停頌點
就抓這個低點跌破
其實空間不會很大
那换的就是看有没有机会
去创一个新高
把一个N字形在那儿
都更漂亮一点点
这个是第三个中阳光的部分
那刚刚提到
其实整个的光镜头
你看我们有无人机
然后有CPU
然后有相关的机器人
所以我帮大家准备好了
什么东西
光镜头族群
其实并不是一个很大的族群
但刚刚讲到的领头羊的双雄
他们是因为还夹带了CPU的题材
不过如果没有CPU题材的好处是什么
就是股价还是相对非常低位阶
而且虽然都叫镜头
但是在各自的领域都有发挥
例如我说机器人股
其实今天机器人股也是有表现的
那机器人相关的光学躺这么久了
是不是也应该还他公道呢
所以艾伦这边很细心
刚刚已经帮大家念过之后
如果有心血的朋友
可以加一下艾伦说的Light At
他会在明天早上
把到底現在各光學鏡頭
擅長在哪些領域跟主題
會來跟大家做一個報告說明
有興趣的話就來掃一下QR Code
那廣告回來的話
我們有大來賓要上場了
他遵守了一個承諾
因為他在股市的資歷非常的深
上次專訪他
他說要來專門教波浪理論
他說他從來沒有跟人家教過
所以今天獨家在招好安倫說
等一下要來教
到底累積了這麼幾十年功力的
波浪理論到底該怎麼看
欢迎回来赵华
请问在股票市场里
有什么事情是你从来没看过的吗
蛮多的吧
蛮多的吗
蛮多的啊
你说从来没看过吗
好像越来越多都看过了
但当台积电会涨停板
或者是说当台湾股市有九成
会跌停板的时候
我自认就看得应该
大概夠多了不過今年啊有很多事情都是不管在股市多久都第一次看見的沒錯例如你有看過台股48,000嗎第一次啊對不對第一次嘛所以如果今天有什麼事情
是我們的來賓
他也沒看過的
那才叫珍惜
是的
沒錯
我們先來歡迎他
就是我們的好朋友
股市師公永年老師
兩位好
各位觀眾朋友大家好
永年老師今天給了我們
一個很酷的slogan
這個連我們常常聽到的
贪婪恐懼
袁老师都可以很接地气的
把它改
别人贪婪我吓死了
别人吓死我就贪婪
对
那现在你是贪婪还是吓死
我现在我不晓得
我也不知道
我到底现在是什么状况
是
我现在就时而贪婪时而吓死
对
我就每天
像我都是每天不一样
那我们比较像
好
就是
我在股市52年了
我们年年数
对 你们一定会问我说
你52年有没有没看过的东西
有没有
对不对
好 我现在正式跟大家讲
我从来没有看过
这么帅跟这么漂亮的组织人工
哎呀
我们几年前有看过
是就进化了是不是
哎呀
是不是
好 OK
其他的我大概差不多都看过了
当然你说四万八千点
我当然是以前都没有看过
是
为什么会有这个标
是因为有一次是
有講到今年台灣的GDP成長率11%
是39年來沒看過的
其實當場的那種
欽佩之心就浮上來了
代表施工對於整個數據
每一年的變化
是時時在掌握的
是 沒有錯
因為在古時候的時候
那個時候台灣的經濟警示
那個GDP的成長率真的嚇死人
可是當時是覺得說
這很正常嘛
因為每年的平均的
這個GDP的成長率
都在10%以上
甚至最高有到17% 18%的
所以我們就覺得很正常
可是39年前之後
就再也沒有看到這種
這個兩位數的
對 就再沒看到了
這一次一看到就是
哇 真的很驚人
其實更驚人的是什麼
更驚人的還有一個就是
我們的這個
整個上市上櫃公司的
平均的他們的這個
它平均的總共的它的營收
這超過了5.79兆
達到5.79兆年增率是47.5%這個很少見好 因為我們下一個標叫52年沒見過的榮景施工都其實該見的都見了除了像今年最大漲點 最大跌點
那當然大家都第一次見
可是確實有很多景氣上的數據
是你不得不說很厲害的
是 真的非常厲害
我們看一下景氣景氣的紅燈
這一次你看
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 八連紅
對不對 連八紅了
那麼史上最長的
這個連紅的記錄是多少
連九紅 就是2021年
疫情就是發生了第二年
那今年看起來是有機會
創這個十連紅
有機會 為什麼說有機會呢
因為我們可以看到現在為止
就到八月份
到八月份為止的時候
其實大家可以看
應該還是紅燈的
應該沒有問題的
那九月份到目前為止看起來
應該也不會差
所以連時紅應該不會有太大的問題
然後這個就是我剛才講的
就是上市貴公司的企業的總營收5.79兆
那麼這個年增率47.5%
嚇死人了
一家企業的它的這個年營收
能夠年增率47.5%
已經很可怕了對不對
整體都是這樣子的話
那你說我們台灣的經濟景氣好不好
好到一個爆炸對不對
那更重要的是
因為我們前一波是屬於資金行情
资金行情的尽头是什么
警惕行情
如果有警惕行情的话
那么这个行情就可以继续下去
那等一下我会来跟大家
用PROUND 语言来跟大家讲说
要怎么样子
为什么我看这个行情
还有机会继续下去
因为现在对资金的杂音
应该就是来自于联准会
现在升息几率非常高
然后全世界的央行都在讲要升息
所以感觉上资金紧缩
那我觉得施工很赞的是
上一次我们专访施工
有提到波浪理論
然後施工說
下一次再來好好聊
今天就一個波浪理論大全餐
要送給大家
想要學的真的
有點需要施工
好好的來教我們
就稍微學一些基本的
我們講一些基本的理論
讓大家來看一下
接下來會怎麼樣
好 現在這一大波
就是從這個
應該是從2008年
2008年
金融海嘯之後
一直到現在
我相信這一路走來很多人都對這個波浪理論到底要怎麼算這波浪到底要怎麼算因為波浪理論它聽起來就是跟海波浪一樣
對不對 海波浪
其實這個傳說中
發明波浪理論的埃瑞特
他就是當年窮途潦倒
就坐到紐約的海邊
麥哈頓的海邊
在那邊看海浪
看了一年兩年以後
就突然發現
有個江湖秘籍
古林秘局藏在裡面
就是大波浪 中波浪
小波浪之類的
傳說中他是這樣子發明的
然後他為什麼會成名
為什麼波浪理論會出來
因為他是全世界第一個
預測出來
美國要爆發經濟大蕭條的人
他當時預測說會有經濟大蕭條
沒有人相信
因為那個時候就擦協同理論
一併就很熱
對 因為熱得不得了
就跟今年五六月
台灣的情況一樣
熱得不得了
你說這個盤會下跌
你保證被轟死對不對
他那個時候就是這樣子
結果呢
我講到最後
最後他也是破產的這個破產
所以我下個結論
貿易理論是個好東西
可是呢
你千萬不要鑽進牛角尖裡面去
我先跟大家講一下
貿易理論你一定要懂
那也是個好東西
可是你鑽到牛角尖裡面
失敗率非常非常的高
先跟大家講一下
有兩種算法
第一個從3955算到
這個2018年的1月11270
這邊算是第一波
這樣也10年
9年多 對將近10年
這個就第一波
時間長度非常的長
非常長
然後這邊回檔是第二波
就是2020年的
到2020年3月8523
就是這個新冠肺炎爆發的時候
最低點8523
然後拉起來
這邊我們把它當作第三波
其實你真正的要算的話
這裡不能當作第三波
為什麼
因為它不符合第三波的要求
可是它有一點是符合的
什麼呢就是
第三波就是主身段
這個要主身段
主身段不能是最短的這個波
那麼你可以看
它第三波看起來沒有漲多少
可是它的漲幅
這286%
第一波漲幅多少 285
所以它不是最短的一波
時間是最短的
可是它的這個
這個長度不是最短的
好 走了第四波 現在第五波
那第五波上來呢
這個我們看這第五波
一二三四五
已經走了五波了對不對
所以現在在整理
那現在整理以後呢
有沒有機會再往上走一波呢
其實是有機會的 是有機會的
等一下我會再跟大家
稍微的講得更詳細一點
那麼還有一種算法是怎麼樣
就是從3955到這個2018年
2018年的11270
這邊當作調整波
調整波還有這個
我們把這邊當作調整波
然後這邊是調整波完之後的整理波
整理了之後
它的調整波是因為金融海嘯之後
那個金融海嘯之後
因為股市跌得太深了
跌太深了就好像一個啤酒
你砸到地上去以後
它要談一談
慢慢的談才重新歸位
重新整理歸位
所以這個叫做調整波
跌升之後的一個整理波
那整理了之後呢
到這邊才開始呢
這個8523
就是2020年的8523
那我們才把它當作
第一波來算的話
這邊的話就是第一波
然後第二波
那這裡呢
大家會講說
第二波不是應該ABC往下走嗎
可是有一種整理波是
它的一二
這ABC
西坡的高點比這個A坡的高點還要高
這個叫做高角度的整理
這是非常強勢的
如果你波浪這個算對的話
你在這裡的時候
你就會開始大買股票了
你就會強力買股票 為什麼呢
因為呢它的西坡的高點
比A坡的高點高
因為理論上來講
西坡的高點應該要比
A坡的高點低才對
因為這是往下整理
要往下整理
結果呢它這邊是往上整理
所以這裡我們把它當作第一波的話
這邊當作第二波的整理
現在是第三波
現在是主身段
那麼後面整理完第四波以後
還會有個第五波的再度的分出
這個是兩種不同的算法
所得到的結論
所以這就是我跟大家講
因為一張圖可以
你問十個人
大概會有十一種的答案給你
每個人的算法不一樣
可是你要挑兩個就是比較有可能性的來做參考可能性比較高來做參考所以不管它現在是主身段還是已經開始
這邊已經開始進入第四波的整理波了
這個第四波整理波
一般來講我先跟大家講一下
第二波它的整理波
如果是比較複雜
就是A B C D E
五波的平台式的整理的話
那麼它的第四波
通常就是A B C波的三波的整理
反過來也一樣
這個可能要錄影下來
然後大家回放
請大家何去反覆回放
因為時間關係
我只能就很快的帶過去
同樣的如果這第二波
是個很簡單
簡單波的話
就是A B C波的整理的話
那第四波通常就是
五波的橫向的整理波
會不會出現呢
再跌破前一波的低點
就是跌破39,000點
然後再往下跌
我覺得以現在的
整個國際的情勢來講
我不排除這個可能性
我不排除這個可能性 OK 好
這個用月K從2008到現在
已經是快要這個20年了
我喜歡後面第二套的答案
就是我們現在還在第三波而已
主聲波裡面
現在應該在第四波了
大概要整理個五到八個月吧
是
從七月開始起算了
整理五到八個月
OK 好 那如果是這樣的話
那我們就可以幾乎可以肯定
還會有下一波的
第五波的行情
OK 好 那再接下來呢
波浪理論它是怎麼發明出來的
除了我剛剛講的
艾瑞特沒事跑去海邊看
看這個潮汐之外
那其實它真正的
這個是從哪裡出來的
從黃金切割率出來的
黃金切割率是自然界
它的一個這個
應該說天然的數據
它就很合乎的
大家都知道黃金切割率吧
應該都知道嘛
就是說那個
摩特爾達身材的黃金比例有沒有
就是這個意思
葦翠檸檬黃金比例
對 OK
那黃金切割率呢
其實它就是把一分成兩個部分
一個是0.618
一個是0.382
這個是全是
就是有史以來
就是自然界最完美的比例
就是這個下半身的長度是0.618
上半身是0.382
哇 那身材好得不得了
在從黃金切割率呢
古時候在意大利有個和尚就是修飾了我們中國叫和尚OK 好 那有個尚呢因為閒著無聊他就養兔子養兔子之後他就發現了
這個沸泊男子系數
因為他名字叫沸泊男子
OK 發明的人叫沸泊男子
對…然後發明了這個系數
叫沸泊男子系數
所以就是一隻兔子
到後來變成兩隻
兩隻就生了三隻
三隻就生了五隻
五隻生了八隻 OK
一隻呢最大數是144隻
那144隻以後會怎麼樣呢
就吃掉了
OK 好
養活一個修道院的人
對 就養太多了
好 那麼就是最大數是144
大家覺得為什麼是144呢
來 我跟大家講
你去拿計算機除以除除看
144除以89是多少
0.618
這個1.618
OK 所以它是黃金
其實是從黃金切割率
演變出來的
一連串的這個系列的數字
所以它原本是從這邊開始出發
一隻兔子
然後再慢慢的
就可以兩隻三隻
它這個圈
這個螺旋的圈就變得越來越大
因為它是一個樹一個樹
連接起來的
就變成像這個鸚鵡螺一樣
他們鸚鵡就長這樣
對 就是長這個樣子
所以鸚鵡螺它其實
它也是符合黃金缺貨率
符合的 好
那麼再講一個題外話
麻將有多少張
138張再加上
136張加上八支花
144張
麻將
所以麻將
麻將厲不厲害
很厲害
它符合自然界的大術法則
然後呢
這個普克派有多少張
52張
52張跟144
沒有在裡面是嗎
沒有
所以呢
它不符合自然的定律
我只要講
我讲这个麻将是很有学问的
非常有学问的东西
好 那么这个是题外话了
OK 好 重点来了
这边有写简单懂哦
对
我怎么觉得很困难
没有很困难
好多数字啊
这个其实就是跟大家讲
这个是基础的这个波浪理论
是
波浪理论它分成一个攻击波
还有一个调整波
攻击波就是呢
这个一二三四五
五波
然後這個調整波就是ABC
所以呢這個這邊是五波
這邊是三波所以一個大波段一個完整的大波段它是一共有八波的等於五波上攻 三波下跌對 那所以一個大波段一個完整的大波段它是一共有八波的五波上攻 三波下跌對 那所以呢就變成那個
非波男子係數裡面有八 對不對
一二三五八
那其實剛剛那個非波男子係數
其實大家看起來好像覺得很難
其實不難
你就是把前面兩個數加起來
就是第三個位數
然後呢
第二第三再加起來
就變第四個位數
就是這樣子
OK 好
那麼五大坡加三大坡等於八大坡
那每一個攻擊坡裡面
像是這邊就是一個攻擊坡
這攻擊坡裡面
每一個攻擊坡
它又分成一二三四五
每一個攻擊坡還是再分五坡
對 就是五個中坡
那這五個中坡加起來
一共有二十一個小坡
還要小坡就對了
對 還有一共二十一個小坡
为什么是21个小坡
来算给大家看
这边不是五坡吗
这边是五个小坡
这个中坡是有五个小坡组成的
五个小坡组成之后
它回档是三个小坡
5加3等于8
5加3等于8就16了
那这边只有上升坡
没有调整坡了
所以这边五坡
16加5就是21
所以光阳系数里面有个21
OK 好
那你调整坡呢
它又分成三個中波段
那在這邊就加起來
1 2 3 4 5
然後1 2 3
再1 2 3 4 5 就13波
所以一個完整的波段
它是一共有多少 34波
34波 好 然後呢
那攻擊波呢
第一大波到第五波
變成34個小波
加34個小波
加上21波
就變成89波
又是那個
非波難支係數的一個數字
那再加上調整波呢
就是有21個小波
加上13小波
再加上21個小波
等於55個小波
那所以加起來就等於144波
就完整的一個波的
好 其實這樣加
大家只要會加法
對 就加得出來
而且很玄奇的是
它就可以套用到
菲波南茲系數
對 沒錯
可是我覺得最難的就是
大中小波的定義
是 沒錯
我覺得這個就會變成
大家難免說
十個人會有11種結法
所以就是我剛剛講的
你千萬不要鑽牛角尖
因為在差不多將近40年前
那個時候很
這個台灣的證券業裡面
大家都在研究
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕